ce qui devait être un simple voyage en
turquie s'est avéré être un véritable
cauchemar
il s'appelle fabien has all et il est
français il a 43 ans victime de tortures
en prison
c'est l'histoire de ce français fabien
azoulay partie en 2010 est à istanbul
pour faire des implants capillaires
sur place il va faire l'erreur de
commandes et du gbl un produit
stupéfiant qui venait d'être interdite
dans le pays le 27 février 2018 il est
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
si sa peine est réduite à 16 ans et huit
mois fabien vit depuis un véritable
cauchemar loin de sa famille torture
harcèlement humiliation ses conditions
de détention sont inacceptables il
serait même victimes de différentes
discriminations notamment sur le fait
qu'il soit juif et qu'il soit homosexuel
ce week-end une pétition réclamant son
transfèrement en france a été lancé ce
soir son avocate m e carole olivia
monter nos et son meilleur ami david
benhaim sont avec nous pour tenter de
faire sortir fabien des griffes de cet
enfer histoire incroyable merci m carole
olivia montenot merci d'être avec nous
merci à vous merci d'être là on à david
benhaim qui sera avec nos sophie
wiesenfeld david mélé hume son meilleur
ami et sophie wiesenfeld présidente du
comité de soutien de fabien azoulay qui
est avec nous bonsoir sophie merci
d'être là sophie alors on va rappeler
d'abord l'histoire et merci bien sûr
david d'être avec nous fabien azul et il
arrive à istanbul en 2017 pour y subir
une opération chirurgicale on va parler
des implants capillaires c'est ça une
opération c'est juste des implants
capillaires on va pas se moquer il ya
plein de gens qui font ça et qui vont en
turquie pour faire ça c'est moins cher
et ils sont très très bon là dedans donc
voilà c'est très bien fait voilà donc on
va dire la vérité il y est allé pour ça
c'est pas une opération chirurgicale
c'est ça c'est pour faire des implants
capillaires pendant ce séjour il va seul
oui il atterrit à istanbul depuis tes la
ville sur les recommandations de son
médecin à la corte organisées avec la
clinique sur place est très fréquent il
ya des package avec l'hôtel la clinique
pendant son séjour il va commander et se
faire livrer du gbl alors vous demandez
ce que c'est que le gbl le gbl c'est une
drogue de synthèse
c'est ça qui est un excitant sexuelle à
la base oui c'est un détergent pour les
jantes de voiture
d'accord donc quand vous l'acheter quand
vous commandez en ligne
vous commandez sous cette forme là quoi
la cour saint papoul dit oui c'est très
important
et après donc lui comment il commente sa
commande son petit fils dans son petit
lit chagny un site sur un site internet
exactement d'accord sur lequel il a un
compte à son nom d'accord il utilise sa
carte bleue à son nom donc vous imaginez
bien qu'il n'a pas le sentiment qui fait
quelque chose d'illégal
bien sûr parce que s'il avait ce
sentiment là bien évidemment il ne
l'aurait pas fait cette façon là et il
le fait livrer à son nom à son hôtel
là où il réside donc il a vraiment le
sentiment que ya aucun problème à
commander ce produit en turquie d'autant
plus que le site prévoir sur le côté
droit
une liste des pays dans lequel le
produit interdit et la turquie n'y
figure pas pour cause le produit n'a été
classifié comme stupéfiant que quelques
mois auparavant par décret et ça a
échappé à la vigilance du site internet
alors là c'est le début du cauchemar
pour lui qu'est ce qui se passe
donc ils commandent cette substance est
là qui commande le produit oui et au
moment de la réception du colis par les
services de la poste à istanbul les
douanes détecte le produit et devait
rester combien de temps turquie il
devait rester quelques jours le temps de
faire les gens sargasses que ça donc
parfois vous faites des premiers
implants
il ya deux mois à peu près 15 jours que
voilà un maximum d'un maximum d'accord
donc là il donc là ça arrive à la poste
ça arrive à la base d'accords est
détecté par la douane d'accord qui
préviennent la police qui du coup décide
de suivre le colis jusqu'à sa
destination
fabien azoulay dans sa chambre on
l'appelle la réception le dit votre
colis est arrivé
il descend et là la police est en bas de
l'hôtel et l'art est donc là ils
interpellent ils interpellent ils le
pren direct direct
il est placé en détention provisoire il
sait ce qui se passe il comprend ce qui
se passe il fais quoi moi j'interviens
trois mois après donc cette phase là si
vous voulez on sait la famille qui la
gère au départ qui essaye de trouver des
avocats en turquie pour essayer de
trouver une solution impossible sa
famille qu'il apprend en premier c'est
xavier son frère sur xavier son frère
d'accord qui apprend ça qui apprend ça
et qui du coup active un petit peu tous
ses contacts pour savoir quel avocat
prendre sur place qui contacté il a des
nouvelles pas du tout non 0 nouvelle
l'a20 vous intervenez au bout de trois
mois ouais vous avez été une rencontre
en turquie
oui alors il faut qu'ils voient moi j'ai
été à l'audience en accord bien sûr
ensuite j'ai essayé de me rendre au
parloir à la maison d'arrêt oui avec un
permis qui m'a été remis par le
procureur sur place est très compliquée
à obtenir est passé le deuxième barrage
de la maison d'arrêt il nous explique
que les avocats turc n'étant pas les
bienvenus dans les prisons françaises il
est hors de question que je puisse aller
plus loin donc à ce moment là je suis
bloqué donc la seule fois où j'ai pu
voir fabien voulait c'était au moment
des audiences puisque contrairement à la
france sont des audiences qui sont
publiques donc il ya eu ce qu'on appelle
d audience de mise en état ou aussi bien
le procureur que la défense peut faire
des demandes
c'est des audiences qui dure cinq
minutes alors il a fait ce qu'il avait
eu un avocat commis d'office en turquie
ou pas du tout au départ il ya eu un
avocat commis d'office qui a été proposé
par le consulat a commencé consul à
istanbul
au départ on était en contact avec eux
il avait proposé cette avocate
mais très rapidement la famille de
fabien a préféré prendre une avocate qui
était peut-être plus expérimentés dans
le domaine du pénal pour gérer le
dossier alors un an plus tard en 2018 il
va être finalement condamné à 20 ans de
prison
alors on est du coup au mois de février
oui donc quelques mois après son
interpellation et l'information qui à
mon sens très importante et qui peut
expliquer beaucoup de choses c'est que
le président de la cour d'assises
d'istanbul qui a donc suivi les
audiences de mise en l'état dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure ce président qui
donc connaissez le dossier la veille de
l'audience au fond il a été incarcéré
dans le cadre de la purge terre dogan et
donc c'est un nouveau président et une
nouvelle composition de chambre qui au
pied levé a repris le dossier sans le
connaître et au cours d'une audience qui
a duré 15 minutes a prononcé cette haine
folle que vous venez de rappeler et 20
ans qui a été réduite à 16 ans et huit
mois
alors c'est ce que c'est un verdict
exceptionnel ou c ou c ça ne nous a pas
étonné alors ça nous a étonné puisque
l'avocate sûrs que nous a dit ça va être
qualifié de consommation personnelle ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est un produit qui
n'a aucune valeur commerciale
il était interdit depuis très peu de
temps turquie donc je ne suis pas
inquiète
on aura une peine pour la consommation
simple et comme il est étrange et ça
sera deux ans avec rabanne oui mais oui
mais sauf qu'il fait bâtiment c'est à
dire qu'il est renvoyé immédiatement en
france exactement douala qu'il a sa
condamnation mais il reste pas en prison
et rentre c'est pas du tout chez moi
c'est ce qu'ils nous ont expliqué les
avocats tube ce qui restera en turquie
exactement
alors très vite en prison ses conditions
de détention se dégrader et devenir
terrible dans une première mission dans
une première prison il va être même
victime d'une tentative de meurtre
oui alors ça a été qualifiée comme ça
mais en réalité c'est plus des actes de
torture c'est à dire que y'a un de ses
codétenus il assez terrible dans les
lettres qu'il a écrit à ses proches
il explique il a essayé de cacher sa
religion qu'il a essayé de se protéger
au maximum
il explique que certains de ses co
détenus avec des croix gammées sous leur
matelas qu'ils doivent relever en fait
tous les soirs donc quand il sortait de
la cellule ils passaient devant ce
couloir de mac la croix gammée
on allait l'être notamment et est donc
cette agression oui c'est un de ses
codétenus qui le nom azul et évoque
forcément la communauté juive et à
istanbul c'est quand même des prisons
qui sont internationale contrairement à
la prison où il est actuellement
et donc il a décidé en pleine nuit de
faire bouillir de l'eau dans les
marmites et il lui a jeté sur le corps
pendant qu'ils dormaient et en fait
fabien été transféré à l'hôpital bien
évidemment et ensuite il sera changé de
prison quelques semaines après et son
agresseur a bien évidemment été enfin je
dis bien évidemment mais il aurait pu ne
pas l'être en turquie mais il a été
condamné
il a ensuite été déplacé il est
désormais détenu à 800 km au nord-est
d'istanbul dans une prison difficile
d'accès où il partage sa cellule avec
huit autres co détenus
c'est ça comment est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles parce que là on a des
lettres un de fabien puis kabato quatre
ans il vit un enfer il parfois et il
change avec ses proches par courrier
notamment avec avec son meilleur ami
david david david et sophie présidente
du comité de soutien de fabien boulay
sophie est ce que vous avez des
nouvelles dernièrement de fabien non non
je les aime
j'ai des nouvelles uniquement via son
frère xavier qui peut lui parler
chaque mardi mais les nouvelles qu'il a
sont hélas très mauvaise il prend
beaucoup de médicaments pour passer la
douleur morale et il le veut ne veut pas
terminer de la quatrième année qui sera
en septembre dans cette prison ils
pensent ils à des pensées suicidaires et
ses jours sont vraiment content et il
est en danger de mort david beinheim est
avec nous vous êtes le meilleur ami de
fabien bonsoir merci david d'être là
david vous vous il vous a écrit n'a pas
écrit je lui ai écrit on a eu des
pratiques et des transferts de prison de
donc les courriers n'ont pas pu arriver
on à communiquer énormément à travers
vous aviez et je trouve que moi je
l'attendais d'été en turquie je
l'attendais à tel-aviv à ce moment là
ils devaient me retrouver en septembre
fin septembre et donc j'ai je me suis
inquiété j'ai appelé immédiatement que
vous aviez que je ne connaissais pas
très bien son frère exactement et donc
est donc au fur et à mesure on a on a
échangé à travers xavier les lettres
qu'il a envoyées terrible alors quand un
calvaire il raconte j'ai détecté des
avoirs de ces cellules des des lettres
alors pour trouver qu'on va publier à
partir de demain je vais les lire un
petit saut au téléspectateur merci david
alors dit quand je regarde mon acte de
condamnations qui dit libération le 23
mai 2034
j'ai le coeur qui bat plein pot je ne
tiendrais pas jusque là je le sais je le
sens je n'en n'aurai pas la force
tu sais ici il n'y a pas de présomption
d'innocence comme il y en europe et aux
états unis
c'est un système qui condamne quelles
que soient les circonstances cette peine
de 20 ans est tellement inconcevable
dans une de ses lettres aussi fabien
explique à quel point il n'est pas fait
pour ce monde d'horreur et de violences
dans cette prison personne ne peut
imaginer les horreurs auxquelles j'ai
assisté ce n'est juste aucun voilà par
consommables ici que ce sont tous des
récidivistes ils ont l'habitude des
prisons mais moi non je ne sais pas je
ne sais même pas me défendre
en fait je crois que tout est étudié
pour faire souffrir au maximum ici c'est
une prison psychologique comme ils
disent je veux dire d'autres passages 1
deux lettres justement dans un dans la
revue littéraire la règle du jeu ils
vont les publier pour nos
téléspectateurs ils vont les y aura
aussi la version manuscrite de lettre
bouleversante
m carole au liban nous tenons quand il
parle de ses horreurs il se passe qu
actuellement pour lui alors là ce que
vous décrivez donc c'était à l'horizon
de malte est là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quand il parle d'une prison
psychologique il est enfermé 24 heures
sur 24 dans l'air que même si en france
on a des conditions de détention qu'ils
sont terribles également il ya quand
même une cour de promenade
d'accord mais là il n'y a pas de cours
de promenade et il avec lui des doutes 8
à l'autre des druides dans sa cellule
mais qui en fait et c'est ça qui est
très dangereux qui en fait accessible
par toutes les cellules qui sont autour
pendant la journée en fait il ouvre
toutes les portes et donc les détenus
peuvent se balader au sein de cette
cellule géante qui est divisé en cellule
de 9
et ça c'est dangereux parce que vous
pouvez pas contrôler ce qui se passe la
jointure s'ils peuvent d'une cellule à
l'autre se déplacer sans qu'ils aient
besoin d'un gardien pour ouvrir et
vérifier ce qu'ils vont faire
c'est ça qu'il met énormément en danger
alors il a écrit notre lettre que je
vous lis c'est si incroyable ce qu'il
décrit j'aurais dû commencer cette
lettre il ya une semaine mais ma tête
parfois c'est un complètement face aux
horreurs auxquelles je fais face
quotidiennement
la dernière en date est un type qui
s'est fait trancher la gorge par un
groupe de quatre syriens je dormais
quand c'est arrivé mais les cris des
détenus m'ont réveillé la vue du sang
partout était effrayante pire que dans
un film d'horreur
j'ai appris par la suite que le détenu
qui est décédé à et fait des avances à
l'un des syriens etc au nom d'allah il
devait le payer de sa vie fait de son
homosexualité bien entendu je suis
depuis le début d'un retour dans le
placard et personne ne sait que je suis
folle je suis passé par une très
mauvaise période où je ne répondrai pas
aux courriers et je me laisser couler
peu à peu je rêvais de ma mort une nuit
j'ai même vu ma pierre tombale
on rêve tu sais quand on est en prison
on n'arrive pas à raisonner
rationnellement
alors j'ai vu ses rêves comme peut-être
des signes prémonitoires si j'avais le
moyen de passer en douceur crois moi je
l'aurais déjà fait qu'est ce qu'il est
possible aujourd'hui
de faire on sait que les rats la
relation entre la turquie et la france
sont très très tendue aujourd'hui le
gouvernement français ne peut rien faire
tout le monde nous demande pourquoi on a
attendu aussi longtemps
oui la réponse c'est que déjà il y avait
le temps judiciaire en turquie d'accord
où on ne s'attendait pas à une telle
condamnation est ensuite la procédure de
transfèrement c'est quelque chose qui
est très long nous on a voulu laisser le
ministère des affaires étrangères
travailler sans pression
c'est à dire avec les us et coutumes de
ce ministère qui sont compliquées
puisque ça implique des relations
internationales et notamment avec la
turquie
et donc ils nous ont demandé de ne pas
médiatiser pour les laisser travailler
on a respecté ce souhait du ministère
des affaires étrangères sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on arrivait un constat
simple c'est que la demande de fabien
pour son transfèrement elle a été faite
en mai 2019 reçu en novembre 2019 déjà
je trouve ça fou que ça met autant de
temps juste pour recevoir une demande de
subvention herman alors on ne parle de
ma vie qu'aujourd'hui les autorités
françaises vous dise quoi c'est aucune
réponse c'est silence radio
la langue de bois alors j'ai eu un appel
aujourd'hui ok d'accord 3 4 jours un peu
où là j'ai eu un appel de la protection
des détenus à l'étranger mais ça
n'avance pas là on a eu une réunion au
quai d'orsay au mois de mars où nous on
s'attendait à voir énormément de
réponses puisque la région du mois de
novembre c'était suite à l'agression
on nous avait supplié de pas médiatisé
on nous avait promis que tout serait mis
en oeuvre
et là on arrive le 12 mars et on n'a
aucune réponse alors moi je dis pas
c'est la faute d'untel plus que d'un
autre en vérité j'en sais rien tout ce
que je constate c'est que rien n'a bougé
alors que ce soit de la faute des turcs
ou des français savaient bien égal et je
leur dis simplement vous avez vos
différents mais aujourd'hui il ya la vie
d'un homme de langue je vois c'est pas
sûr qu'on a un espoir on a encore
l'espoir on a un espoir savez le nouvel
ambassadeur à léona nerfs il est arrivé
il nous a donné beaucoup d'espoir il a
dit je viens ici parce que je veux un
apaisement dans les relations franco
turques moi je n'ai entendu quand il est
là ça m'avait cible rejoindre on l'a
contacté
on a remis une lettre en main propre je
me suis déplacé personnellement à
l'ambassade
je n'ai pas eu de retour à ce jour ces
deux de l'ambassade de turquie en france
et pourtant il dit clairement qu'ils y
voient un apaisement dans les relations
moi je vais laisser cette possibilité il
y avait des possibilités que sa soeur
n'a rien répondu
moi c'est pas lui personnellement que
j'ai rencontrés mais je sais que il a eu
cette lettre en main propre je le sais
mais joindre le look où les idées
personnes du gouvernement 2 parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est si si on a envoyé
des lettres à tout le monde vous
imaginez bien qu'on est alors on n'a pas
de retour ou alors des retours type
ministère des affaires étrangères oui
nous prenons ce cas très au sérieux nous
faisons notre maximum
mais c'est quoi le maximum en fait
montrez-moi des courriers de relance que
vous avez envoyé aux autorités turques
montrez-moi un dossier moi je peux pas
accepter quand je vais dans une réunion
au quai d'orsay que la personne qui est
en face de moi qui me parle elle a une
feuille son pupitre
c'est pas normal montrez-moi les
diligences oui moi aussi j'ai un client
qui est pas content du travail que je
fais sort le dossier voilà ce que j'ai
fait et nous on est client du quai
d'orsay je suis désolé mais il travaille
pour nous donc un moment donné il faut
qu'ils nous apportent des résultats on
va on va essayer de dessiner à notre
petit niveau de faire bouger les choses
peut-être au niveau de l'ambassade de
turquie peut être au niveau
je pense que c'est c2c admire personne
appelée je pense que c'est j'adore lancé
voilà exactement
on va essayer de faire bouger les choses
dès cette semaine
essayez peut-être d'avoir l'ambassadeur
de turquie en france dans l'émission
dans les prochains jours pour qu'il nous
donne sa réponse et pour qu'il essaie de
faire bouger les choses parce que là il
ya urgence et on espère qu'on va pouvoir
voilà je crois que ça va ça va bouger
même si on va pas se mentir il ya peu
d'espoir va pas dire ça on ne peut pas
dire qu'il ya peu d'espoir je veux que
je peux je me refuse c'est bien ça vous
avez raison on va essayer de faire le
maximum en tout cas et c'est vrai qu'il
faut essayer de médiatiser le pousse les
éditions voilà même si mais c'est vrai
que la turquie et la france sont
extrêmement tendues et c'est aussi et
que la grèce en plus par ailleurs par
exactement oui oui il ya david qui
voulait rajouter un mobile syrie je
voudrais dire d'abord que fabien sait
bien qu'un de bien c'est un bosseur
c'est quelqu'un qui se réveiller tous
les matins pour ouvrir le spac il est
ouvert à new york avec lien il est venu
on s'est créé une communauté une famille
on était des expatriés c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est rencontrés aux états unis
c'est un mec bien c'est quelqu'un de
gentil il n'y a pas plus gentil plus
généreux
donc de voir cette souffrance et de voir
à quel point ils essaient de communiquer
avec ses amis il dit à quel point ces
lettres lui donne du bonheur il serait
très content d'avoir entendu les blagues
que vous avez pu faire avant et et il
aurait il envie qu'on lui raconte cette
vie donc on a envie de pouvoir refaire
vivre fabien et lui redonner ce sourire
que vous voyez sur ces photos david ans
et ça vaut vraiment le masque on va
vraiment essayer de faire le maximum
j'apprends à toutes les bonnes volontés
pour nous aider signez la pétition
envoyer des messages à fabien le comité
de soutien la famille toutes les
organisations de défense de droits de
l'homme
on a besoin vraiment de toutes les
bonnes volontés et moi je suis assez
même très optimiste alors qu'ils sortent
ils ont des salaires serait très
rapidement en france
eh ben on espère vraiment sophie on va
faire le maximum et je vous dis cette
semaine on va essayer dès demain nous
ont contacté l'ambassadeur pour voir ce
qu'il peut faire et essayer
voilà de lui dire même de venir ici pour
essayer de lancer un appel ou peut-être
même voilà essayer de voir comment on
peut faire au plus vite mais il faut
garder espoir vous avez bien raison et
j'espère qu'on va y arriver en tout cas
il ya urgence merci m
ce week end à chauffer merci très très
vite j'aimerais beaucoup que ça
deviendra un rendez-vous comme quand
thierry ardisson avait fait pour michaël
blanc c'est vraiment formidable c'est
comme ça que pourrait nous aider et les
lettres seront demain dans le site la
règle du jeu j'invite tous les
téléspectateurs à lire celle est
bouleversante
vous avez l'art très bonne idée sophie
merci en tout cas avoue sophie et merci
à david et continuez votre combat
on lâche rien et on va essayer voilà de
que cette issue vous voyez une issue
heureuse si on peut dire heureuse dans
les produits mais pas seulement